I see,
you said you've come up with four solutions, but
it's all about hitting the numbers, or just hitting your head
can sometimes break the truth and turn it into a new truth.
The key to deciding whether to approve or disapprove of the bills proposed at the assembly, the after-party council, may be the key
.  I have a lot of data and evidence to explain that
it is. How can I overturn it and not pass the bill
? That's where I can show my skills.
If it's short, people with voting rights have horizontal connections, and
it's too risky to express a contrary opinion at the last
minute.
Irresponsible and unaware decision-makers should think what they think after mailing
it That's scary, isn't it?
Not obsessed with justice or even truth
Even if the conclusion is unjust and misleading, if the majority of the tens of thousands of site visitors support it,
they
win.  Everyone will study and vote irresponsibly The
Nara Assembly Anything
goes Hiding and deceiving real data Kurume means black is white If
you unfold a number of contradictory answers and still pass one ice and enough heat there
[music] A
place where you can turn fiction into truth
[music]